sometimes there's little accidents of
fate that come up in my life you know
you have those deja vu moments or
there's something in the air
yesterday my wife has no idea that
you're coming on the show none at all
and we're trying to think of a funny
really great funny movie
uh to show my son
and who's 16
and we're constantly trying to think if
you probably had this where you want to
watch a good movie you want to show
someone a good movie and you're faced
with all the movies in the world and
you're trying to think of what's the
funny one my wife and i are trying we've
shown him so many good movies and then
my wife out of the blue just said bottle
rocket
and i was like yeah bottle rocket and
then i said you know i'm talking to luke
tomorrow and she was like
on the podcast and i said no i'm just
going to his house to talk to him
through his window i was a real wise ass
which i don't often do with my wife and
i'm like no i'm going to go to his house
and talk to him through his window and
she was like [ __ ] off and i said i want
a divorce and so that's ending um
but we brought up bottle rocket
yesterday and then i realized uh that's
the first time
i heard of you owen
wes
anderson was i think in
what about 96 or 95
when my late night show was still really
new
there was this movie everyone was
talking about bottle rocket and that's
kind of i mean i knew you guys were
making shorts before that but this was
your first yeah that was the that was
the first movie we made bottle rock and
yeah i think it was about i think we
might have made it in about 94 or 95 and
then
they wanted to sit on it for a year
because they could feel that it was such
a groundbreaking film
take the town by storm
uh but no i think it wound up coming out
in about uh 97. um but yeah that would
happen when i first met you yeah and i i
know that i was i wasn't sure did you
come on the show then for butterworth i
know that owen did i remember thinking
does this guy have a brother i would
prefer
is there a younger preferable brother
um
and uh and
and sure enough because you ended up you
and i
you've been on the show a lot and i've
always clicked with you but that's the
first time
i saw you guys was in that movie which i
really loved and then
um another thing that's been in the
atmosphere lately is uh is you know
james khan just passed and he's in that
movie and he's terrific because i saw
him
i mean
how amazing that you're these two young
guys these punks who make this movie and
you got the great james khan to be in it
yeah he he um
he was so great on that movie and i
think uh i think probably what got him
into it was the fact that james l brooks
was producing it right right um because
yeah we were it was you know wes
anderson and then
uh owen and andrew and myself
and um yeah i think uh he probably would
have just done it on the strength of
james l brooks i don't know that you
know the script maybe would have
appealed to him that much but yeah he
couldn't have been nicer actually went
to the
um
in in santa monica they were showing the
wild bunch last night on 70 millimeter
and went to see it
and a guy named
paul cedor like a
peck and paw scholar and writer gave a
little speech before but he had a he
mentioned james khan and uh david werner
and uh
two other guys from kind of the pecking
paw stable right and then he had a
little moment of silence for those guys
which was really nice he had it in the
movie theater and uh but yeah james khan
he
you know he was
el dorado has been on lately and just
incredible to think that that guy would
have been connected back to you know
robert mitchum and john wayne and he
couldn't have been nicer to us on the
movie i think there were definitely
you know when he died i was kind of
talking with owen about it just saying
those first couple of days you could
definitely see in his eyes like okay
what am i doing here i'm in a trailer in
a parking lot in dallas these guys are
very odd
um but then he but then he really kind
of warmed up to us so yeah you know it
was one of those people that was really
fun to talk to about different movies he
worked on you know we
we were asking him about brando and he
was like yeah you know brando it was
like it was like you guys with me
and
uh and that and that really was kind of
how we work isn't that crazy when uh
just someone like that can drop a name
like brando and and then somehow liking
it to you and you think no
yeah yeah i mean yeah but it's just so
amazing because i know you guys are
incredible film buffs yeah you and your
brother just like really as kids
you know growing up in in dallas really
you were really into film yeah really in
the movies and i i got to be
friends with harry dean stanton over the
years and got to work with him a couple
times and harry dean was one of those
guys you know wouldn't text so you'd
have to call him and
um call and have these kind of funny
long conversations and then he'd kind of
click off and take a call and
a couple times he'd click back over and
say
i gotta go that's marlon
oh my god
isn't that crazy yeah just unbelievable
and then those guys would chat about you
know how they were both nothing and
nothing mattered yeah no it's just uh
i was at a
party once and i'm a huge beatles
fanatic and paul mccartney's there and i
come into i walk into a room and he's
there playing a guitar but he's playing
it uh because he's
left-handed he's playing it upside down
and backwards because it's strung for
righty
and i just said wow i don't know how you
do that and he's like oh you know what i
was going up in liverpool uh you know
what i'd nick john's guitar and if i had
you know and i'd play it this way it was
the only way i could because i'm lefty
but if i had restrung it he'd have
crippled me and i'm like you can't just
talk about john like that
that's you know what i mean it's the
same thing like well brando's on the
line i gotta go
and then i just think i'm not in this
reality well i mean it is incredible to
me and i i mean i think about it now
when people like james khan dies that
you know you're
we're kind of the same age but we did
we're lucky enough to know people like
that you know from you know the 50s and
stuff like that oh my god i think
i think that you know paul you know the
kind of the first generation or the
maybe the second generation of rock and
roll
um just that you know these guys who
really were pioneers so pretty
incredible the chance you get to talk
anytime i'm even in the room even i
don't get to talk to them if i'm just in
the room
uh on our late night show once we had uh
scottie moore was on who was elvis's
original guitarist and he's in the room
in sun session
at sunset at sun studios when they just
accidentally are messing around and they
cut that's all right mama and he's with
bill black and it's part of the original
lineup and
he was on the show and he was messing
around with the band
and i just said uh you know um excuse me
mr moore okay could you show me how you
play the the solo in that's all right
mama you know
and he said oh yeah sure
it goes like this and he does it and his
hands are doing the same thing they did
in 1954 when he and this
very strange kid
uh changed
yeah truck driver um changed the world
and
i always have the same feeling which is
i don't deserve to be here seeing this
you know it's just an immediate but then
i think well just be here shut up
take those negative thoughts away and
just be here yeah i got to
one time uh
know the guy steve wertheimer that runs
the continental club in austin you know
that little tiny kind of famous blues
club and
uh
i'd run into him
and he'd said that james burton was
going to be doing a little sound check
one afternoon so got to go listen to
like an hour and a half sound check it
was just kind of the same thing to think
about you know he was kind of the next
iteration of scotty moore yeah he's uh
elvis's uh guitar player in uh in the
sort of the vegas years and then played
with ricky nelson and all those guys yep
and did you read the the girl nick book
about uh sam phillips you must read that
yes i did in fact i i saw you do that
great uh interview with you and peter
girl nick where you were so funny you
were like kind of an incorrigible uh
student where
you were like you started kidding around
about something but he wouldn't quite
start laughing he was like yeah well yes
come on enough okay let's stay on the
subject
i've never been able to stay on the
subject you kept going at it and going
at it yeah yeah so you saw me fail well
no no
you didn't fail in in your knowledge
yeah just you got a a little immature
for peter i think i think i did just
kind of wrote it out he's such a great
yeah that happened sometimes where i'm i
i can you know sometimes i'm i mean
peter grommick is just one of the great
scholars
rock and roll of all time an amazing
writer and
just one of those people that's elevated
rock and roll
um you know great writers should be
writing about rock and roll and blues
and uh so he's just a genius and i was
interviewing him and then of course my
natural conan came out and he just had
to forge ahead
he really did you could see it kind of
physically kind of hit him in the
interview
just kind of go through his body like
kind of an electric shock
you're